Hello, I'm Gav.
I'm Dan.
We're the Slow Mo Guys,
doing a giant balloon June, still.
Such a terrible name.
I know.
I regret it.
Well, you've, you've committed now.
This week is based on a
video that I was sent.
Tweeted a few times.
I think it was a gif
someone took from a video.
'Cause that's how the
internet does it these days.
It was a giant balloon, on
a trampoline, full of water,
popping and showering
some kids underneath.
So, I guess I'm going to be
representing the kids in this.
You can represent two kids.
I'll fill a balloon on top,
and hopefully you will
get absolutely annihilated
by a tidal wave of water.
Just get washed away.
You'll just get washed down.
'Kay.
But, hopefully, you won't get crushed.
That's a good point.
I might drown though,
Although, maybe the weight of the balloon
will push the trampoline
Great.
onto you.
Probably.
We'll see.
Knowing my luck.
All right.
Why don't we start?
Start filling up, I'll
get under the trampoline.
All right.
Gettin' soaked today.
Okay, I'm gonna take this mike off again.
Alright.
Oh no, my shoes were under it.
Did they get wet?
Yeah.
So annoying.
Why'd I put them there?
Oh, I'm getting dripped on, brilliant.
It's gonna be like
Chinese water torture at the beginning.
Rolling.
What, I told you.
Oh God, it went in my eye.
Ahhh.
Yeah, you're gonna have
to be in the middle of it.
There's still some
sunshine on me here, so.
Oh, that was a bad decision.
What was?
Uh, oh.
What?
There is all these little drips like this,
and I brushed them away,
and then they all went into
one bit and just peed on me.
Do a voice memo under there D.
All right.
Ooh.
'Kay, doing a voice memo.
What's the statistics say for
how waterproof a phone is?
Water resistant to how much?
Splash resistant.
Splash resistant?
Would you say this is a splash?
Yeah, it's a very big splash.
Yeah.
Sure, alright.
What's it like under here then?
Oh, that's quite nice, this.
Yeah, it'in it?
Sort of like,
you got about 20% of the solar thing.
If that.
So, how far down you
think it's gonna to get?
Well, I think we can get it
down to, like, my nose here.
I think we can get it
down to pretty there,
and if you're under it,
then it'll be about here.
'Cause your nose...
Every time.
Sorry.
Every damn time.
Should I try and fall asleep?
Yeah.
So, it's just like a complete surprise.
Could do.
Pretty tired actually.
Do you want a snack or anything?
Yeah.
What do you want?
What do you got?
I'll have a look.
Got some Hula Hoops though, green ones.
What kind of flavor is that?
Cheese and onion.
off.
Yeah.
Why don't you got that in your hand?
Little teasers.
Are these, , cheese and onion?
Well, this is a pretty ridiculous set up
we got right now.
Dan's under the trampoline
eating a Hula Hoop.
Imported.
Oh, all right.
Balloon's on top.
Phantom lookin' under the trampoline.
I'm starting to lose my mind into this.
Really?
Yeah, 'cause I can't focus on the,
on the surface of this.
Not with two eyes anyway.
How are the springs lookin'?
There's now a gap in the coils.
Oh man.
Probably about half a ton
of water in there though.
The only place it's leaking is on my knob.
It's literally the only
place it's drippin'.
It's started to look quite
unpleasant under there.
Nah.
You all right?
Yeah.
Is it big yet?
[Gav} Uh, it's big.
Yeah?
What if I don't make it?
What if you die?
Yeah.
I think you wouldn't.
You think so?
It's touching me now here.
Is it?
Probably, like, leaning on me.
It's a strain happening there.
Oh, God.
It's pretty big.
Well, there's no, it's
literally on me here.
I'll see if I can make
myself some room to breathe.
Oh, that's like crushing me, yeah.
[Gav} What's the most squashed
you've ever been in your life?
Well, I was bundled at lower school.
Oh, God.
Good Lord.
That was quite a lot of water.
I was, like, under water for ages.
That was severe.
Oh, man.
It's got, like, God.
All right, playing it back.
It looks so weird, whoa.
Oh, it's just dumping.
God.
It's like a dunk tank.
Doesn't even look like water.
It's just so solid.
Oh God.
Look at my feet.
Your feet are raising up.
Like, what?
Oh man, absolute showering.
It looks like one of those, you know,
the storm sensations you
see in, like, in the sea.
Yeah.
Where it's just like a
wall of water, it's like,
I would love to see that
through a trampoline
that's in the ceiling.
It's like the biggest shower head ever.
Yeah, I want a shower head
like that, that'd be so good.
Would you enjoy that, a shower like that?
If all your showers lasted two seconds,
but they were like that.
Yeah.
That was an absolutely gargantuan shower.
Got annihilated there.
I kind of, you know what?
It wasn't too bad, apart
from being crushed.
I think I want one of those in my house.
I want to just go into
a room, push a button,
and then that happens to me.
I mean, can't say it's not efficient.
You'd never be late for work.
Yeah.
Oh, I need a shower.
I'm done.
That'd be great, yeah.
If you had one, a big
one for hot air as well,
it'd be even better.
Oh, it'd be amazing.
You know what would be good
is not telling people that
that's what was happening.
Like, a fella like, oh,
can I borrow your shower?
Yeah, yeah, sure, just go in there.
How's it work?
I'm sure if you weren't expecting that,
you'd just be knocked on your ass.
You probably would.
Yeah.
Well that was a great shower.
Shout out to whoever sent us
that video back in the day.
It was probably years ago at this point.
So, I can't remember who it was,
but if you sent us that clip,
or that gif, or whatever, cheers.
We finally got around to shootin' it.
And I'm surprised you can
actually see under a trampoline.
Yeah, that's good work actually.
With a Phantom.
Decent.
Feel free to follow us on Twitter.
Thank you for watching giant balloon June.
And we'll see you in the next video.